tu fais des guerres tu crées le plus grand
empire d'Europe tu construis le plus grand
palais du monde mais dès que tu
poses les yeux sur une belle femme tu es
du mastic dans la main depuis que je suis
adolescent j'aime les femmes que ma mère devait
mettre  des barreaux aux fenêtres pour m'empêcher de
sortir furtivement pour rendre visite à une des
femmes de chambre
ça n'a pas marché bien sûr j'ai maintenant une
femme et une maîtresse marquise de Montes
pour les capricieuses exigeantes jalouses et la
plus grande beauté du palais sais-tu
comment elle se tient  sa peau si douce
avec une crème à base de bouse de vache
et comment elle fait briller ses yeux en
buvant des mules dans lesquelles tu es tous les matins
peut-être qu'elle adore les bijoux vêtements les
carrosses mon dernier cadeau était d'apprivoiser les ours
oui les
ours tout ce qu'elle était bouleversée par l'attention
Je donnais à un certain homme qui était de la
charmante jeune femme de Tom, mais
entre vous et moi,
idiot de toute façon, d'après ce que j'ai compris,
le marquis a mis les ours dans l'homme, il était l'
aîné des appartements de Thomas, heureusement,
la jeune femme jouait aux cartes à ce
moment-là.  sinon elle aurait subi
le même sort que son canapé bref comme
mon frère comme les nobles comme le
peuple de France le Marquis demande un
gros revenu et un haut degré d'
entretien et je suis sûr que vous devinez
qui doit vous le fournir